This last section will wrap up the Source Control and Collaboration course with a few
more final recommendations, providing some tips and resources for you to use as you
work in your collaborative production pipeline.
Starting out, a big one.
Changing file folder names, or as we like to call it, breaking Perforce.
When working with Unreal Engine and Perforce, absolutely avoid renaming whenever possible.
Raining can cause duplication of folders or synchronization disconnect with your data.
Similar issues may arise if you disconnect from version control, rename, and then try
reconnecting your files to Perforce.
Next, we talked about adding files in previous sections of this course, but I want to reiterate,
when marking your files or folders for add, make sure that you select the nested subfolders
for good measure.
This will help Perforce isolate your files and only selecting the parent folder can run
the risk of generating fractured data.
With that said, Perforce has gotten better at the marking for add function in newer
versions, so if you forget to do this, don't worry too much about it.
Just try and make a habit of doing it before marking for add and submitting.
Now, if your data is not syncing, one of the things we recommend is creating a fresh
pull of information that should correct this problem.
To do that, simply right-click on the file or folder in Perforce that is causing you
problems.
Select the Get Revision option to open the Get Revision pop-up menu.
Once open, choose the Force Operation option and click Get Revision.
That will force a fresh pull of all selected data, but be aware that this process will
take some time to replace all those files, so make sure to take a short coffee break
once you start the pull.
Now, let's talk about Perforce and World Partition, and this first recommendation
is to employ data layers when using World Partition.
Spotable actors may also be an option when working with data layers that become
difficult to manage early on in your production.
Keep an eye out for when that happens.
It is also highly recommended that you implement one file per actor, and the reason for
that is because one file per actor will provide you with a hash code that is searchable
in Perforce.
That way, assets created for World Partition in Unreal Engine can then be searched for
in Perforce with that code.
Continuing the discussion about Perforce and World Partition, let's focus a little
more on one file per actor, which can help ensure a file is checked out when adding
it to the World Partition.
Do not leave the World Partition checked out for too long, as this may cause problems
for other users.
Be sure to check in the World Partition when you are finished.
Now, there are two items that are needed for tracking with one file per actor.
As we just mentioned, the package short name, which is the searchable actor hash
code for Perforce, and then the revision control icon.
As you can see in this image, the revision control displays your asset status, and in
this example, that's the question mark, which means that the World Partition asset
is not checked in.
One thing to note here is that the revision control icon is vital when working on a team,
and if it's not active, other users may not see what is checked out, and that can
prevent project validations, which is why Epic Games permanently enables this option
in production.
Now, if you do run into validation errors, open up a blank level and run the validation
process again.
This usually restores the validation due to a dirty save that's being done by Unreal
Engine.
Doing this by closing the World Partition level is currently the only workaround for
this problem.
And one final thing to note here.
One file per actor is enabled by default within the World Partition, and currently
experimental when being used outside of the World Partition.
Now, this course really covered a lot of material, but don't worry, there's more
help out there.
The video links here are amazing resources.
The first YouTube link is a two-hour live stream covering source control in depth, looking
well beyond the initial commits and looking at scaling source control for a project.
The next YouTube link is a source control webinar, looking at each of the source control
options one by one and reviewing some of their technical and usability concerns in
greater detail.
Of course, we have our own documentation from Epic Games that are specific to using
Perforce and source control with Unreal Engine.
And if you're looking for a more Perforce specific document, then Perforce also has
a curated page with all their collected Unreal Engine resources.
A shout out to Sean Spitzer and Ryan Manning for their support in this course
development, and this concludes the Source Control and Collaboration course.
I want to thank you for spending your time working through this course material.